[Applause]
hello
hello look at us in New York look at you
y this is a good color on you this is
for you I love it well happy belated
birthday thank Youk thank you do you go
appreciate it is it 40 you're 42 right
I'm 42 the same age I turned 42 this
year so I heard yeah and it's great over
here like I love 40s 40s is amazing yes
you know what 4S are an exhale yeah yeah
it's an exhale yeah you you can breathe
yeah you're just like you know what oo
yeah yeah yeah I'm better you a good
party I had a I had a very nice party
back in Miami with friends and family on
the beach cuz I'm a I'm I love the water
okay so I wanted to have the water next
to me and uh nice little tinted dinner
yeah some music Vibe easy dinner on the
beach yeah sexy birthday kind of yeah I
like it all right well Dwayne had a
special serenade at his party this is a
weird segue but whatever um we have a
clip of it happy birthday
to
you happy
birthday to
Daddy happy
[Music]
you it makes you want to have more
children like it's like they're so cute
like that that was a surprise right I
had no idea I didn't know she can hit
that Daddy note I didn't like that was a
note right there and when she said daddy
it crushes you and then and puts you
back together yeah she she does it she
she I mean obviously when I look at her
I see my face and my body and all the
things but like just you know her love
for me is just is unmatched so oh it's
so cool she's beautiful beautiful soul
she has a beautiful soul like I love and
there's something so innocent and pure
when children sing like they're not
thinking about anything else other than
it feels good you know what I'm saying
they're not J by anything yet yeah I had
no idea like you know we play around but
like I know she was going to grab the
microphone and just tell everybody be
quiet quiet and do a thing yeah she was
like she was like my moment yeah she
waited like y'all good yeah okay I will
wait till I'm respected yeah it's like a
teacher that's C everybody so wait you
were just in Miami but you were also
recently honored in Miami right I was
yeah how was that um I was honored with
my with a statue I know so that's crazy
yes thank you there a broad statue of
you did you have any input on this
statue by the way I do I do I I knew
before uh the the audience knew um I had
to sit down with with the heat but um it
was great to share it in Miami with the
audience with the with with the fan base
that's been there like that statue is
all of our statue like we all are
invested in the Miami he putting that
statue up and so the fact that it's
going to happen later this year it's
going to be pretty cool so yeah of
course I'm excited and all the things
but it's kind of weird too like there's
a statue of who thinks you like you
what's a statue I don't know it's not
many people have one right like I know
like monuments I don't know like like
you know like it's not I'm alive and so
I'm alive you know what I mean I am not
dead yet no like normally like when you
think of you think of monuments I'm
alive so and I'm like 42 and I'm like
wow I'm getting a statue like I feel
like I should be older in my life I feel
like every time you go to Miami though
you have to take a picture with that cuz
you are alive so I told them like was
like I was asking them like what are
people what are you guys going to do at
night time when people want to come and
enjoy themselves by my statue yeah light
it up yeah and they was like well we may
have security may not I was like well
I'm talking about myself like I may come
at like 2: in the morning like be like
damn I got a statue yeah bring my music
do my Tik toks in front of my own statue
exactly or your podcast or my podcast
right out there here's the why I got a
statue
yeah welcome to the Y yeah welcome to
the Y right behind me I got a statue I
want a statue so we were talking about
in the break a little bit I want to
first get to your podcast I love the why
that's what it's called how did you come
up with the name um because it's
something I've been dealing with my
entire life my name has been misspelled
by where I go no matter where I go in
life y all the way to the hall of fame
they will still misspell my name is
always people always put DW a y mine is
DW ya and so I'm taking my y back okay
right in my name and so if you see my
podcast you see my logo it's after the W
DW Y and so you see the logo the why is
what's highlighted yeah um and so and
also too the why like your why in life
continues to evolve it continues to
change and so it's something that I felt
was great to be able to talk to with
guests like right now conversation topic
like just for even if you're at a dinner
yeah like oh why did you want to do this
or why are you in this relationship or
why like all the go so many different
ways so the why would do anyway are your
conversations do they go in just such
different directions with depending on
who you have on obviously yeah like
asking Pat Riley his why at um roughly
80 years old and asking Carmelo Anthony
who just retired from the game of
basketball his why I'm it's two totally
different wise right and two two
different ways to look at it life yeah
you know know because Pat's looking back
on life and melo's looking what you know
what he has ahead of him and so it's so
interesting to kind of go go with that
question to why I know it's brilliant I
thought it was really smart when did you
think you wanted to start producing
movies because you got two documentaries
out right now one's Oscar nominated is
incredible yeah so when why did you did
you get what I did there why did you go
into producing for my the wife I'm going
to be your street team I'm your street
team um so I feel that I've been a
Storyteller my entire life for me to be
able to accomplish things that I have in
life I had to tell myself the most
unbelievable story ever yeah and so but
there's other people out here who are
great storytellers and have amazing
Stories and so to have the platform that
we have to be able to uplift and to be
able to highlight and to be able to be a
part of those stories that you identify
with to me was very important yeah with
both of the doc that you just talked
about both of the shorts the dads the
sub crew uh and barbar Little Rock these
are things that I personally identify
with whether it's the community I grew
up with that is very similar to The
Barber of Little Rock yeah and and also
being a father of Zia Wade who is
transgender um they deal with that with
dads in in the community and I was
actually a little jealous that I wasn't
there because I'm like I I need that
Community I need a community of fathers
who we I can ask questions to I can
throw things off of so it's just things
I identify with and uh I wanted to be
behind them and support so like why tell
the barber story like why how do you
pick and choose is it because it was
personal is this one yeah it's it's
because person my my partner John margas
and I we sit down and we say what do we
want our ethos to be as 59th in Prairie
and 59th Prairie is where I grew up I
grew up 5901 South prayer in Chicago
yeah and so I try to to try to think
about that Community I try to think
about that neighborhood I try to think
about that young kid or whatever right
and I try to pick stories that kind of
identifies with what you know I ethos is
and so um Arlo Washington shout out to
Arlo Washington who um he's a Barbara
and if anybody know anything about a
Barbara um they he everything first of
all everything but they they're the safe
they're the safe haven in communities
they're the place where you feel the
safest going especially when you don't
have a lot of outlets like they don't
have in Little Rock Arkansas and so for
what he's done in the barber shop
Community by sending over 1500 adults to
school but also too what he did by
starting this uh people's trust which is
u a nonprofit bank for its community so
people can can start small businesses so
people can have money to be able to pay
their bills right and so he is a
economic Warrior he is he is what the
community needs he what our community
needs investing his community he's
invested in his community with his time
with his Resources with his finances
with his relationships uh it's it's it's
beautiful he's a hero well also um the
dads um the documentary so um we have
them here actually so the dads there
there we go yep and what's up
dads and we have the film director
luchina Fisher in our audience as well
as the dad so explain the the
documentary like how does it play out
dads so the dads they uh they get
together so so it's it's a it's a
fishing trip um and I don't know if all
you guys fish like if everyone F right
like it's not something we grew up doing
um but it's a fishing trip and then you
know you start as you watch it's only
like 10 11 minutes max and as you start
watching it um it's just about it's just
about having a community right they're
sitting around the table they're you
know after they fish they go and they
cook the fish together they sit around
the table they start talking about their
kids they start talking about their
Journey as well like your kids have a
journey as a dad you have a journey um
and so just to be able to sit and be
expressive right and sometimes it's it's
hard for for men right just going back
to the masculinity like you don't want
to hear me be expressive or be what is
perceived this week but to be in a
around the table to be around that that
pond and be able to fish and be
expressive and and be vulnerable uh with
what you're dealing with as a parent in
this world um and ultimately you just
want to love you just want everybody
else to love but that's not the world we
live in right and so it was great just
to see them together and just to see
that Community like I said I was like I
want I need that like I need that
Community as well because sometimes you
feel like you out here on your own
supporting your child loving and nobody
understands like no understands yeah oh
no I think it's important and also I
think we can be that world I'm you know
I am a positive person but we can be
that world but we need things like this
it's just simply about loving whoever
they came out to be you know what I'm
saying they came out of the womb whoever
they are like it's that
easy like we like to complicate the hell
out of stuff but like it's that easy is
that easy yeah what's something that you
want to do L what's a dream project
you're doing so much you've done so much
in your life you're only 42 so what
what's like something like a dream that
you want to do and accomplish I got to
be ready we were just talking about this
backstage before I say that I got to be
ready for that dream I think the one
thing about it we all dream for things
and we all want things but we may not be
ready for it when it comes and so I
don't know what it looks like yet um I
would love to to work on your album with
you if you
hey if you're a producer
I can talk in the background I like it I
like it we need another commercial break
you can see the dads on Netflix
everybody Dwayne's Oscar nominated film
The Barber of Little Rock is also
streaming on the new yorker's YouTube
channel check that out and his podcast
the why with Dwayne Wade you've got to
check that out it's available wherever
you get your
[Music]
podcast
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home